I've never been to a red carpet before
I'm looking for the love of my life so
I'm hopefully I'm gonna flirt with some
actors and just be rich and just ignore
everybody for this in my life what's fun
about today is that we're picking out
our clothes for each of ya this is an
award show we need to look good and our
friends at Samsung are topping off our
outfits with a little accessory one of
my favorite photos of curly is right
here little dog she actually likes the
foot with street style and vintage looks
my main goal for curly on this red
carpet is for him to feel himself
something Curly's into right now is his
collared shirts she's also not afraid of
color even though she says she is
I might go real regal with him I don't
know I feel like my gay brain is gonna
explode my mouth literally just watered
I thought the color would be really good
on you I think you could pull it off the
off the shoulder I was like yes you're
gonna love it it's very sexy and to top
it all off our friends at Samsung gave
me this galaxy watch I customized the
face to match my look and now I can hunt
you down when we lose each other mm-hmm
I'd like to see you try
all right desi are you ready I don't
think y'all ready
Oh
let me say how much I love this shoes
the belt and the necklaces it's all like
a fire my galaxy watch it mattress
totally like you look expensive
I feel expensive I'm just gonna be a
lady of leisure from now on I can't be
bothered I have to go now okay I feel
good I'm just ready to stun everybody
yes yeah meet all these celebs
are you serious I'm too rich to talk to
you now